bonjour à tous merci merci d'être venu
aujourd'hui aussi nombreux alors euh je
vais inviter tout de suite à me
rejoindre sur scène pour cette table
ronde particulièrement vaste qui est
celle de l'environnement
euh les personnes qui ont accepté
d'intervenir Bernard deessel Didier
raout Marcel k mais également Daniel Mac
et Louis ngre et on fera la partie en
lien avec la biodiversité juste après
parce qu'on aura pas assez de place
sinon sur sur scène donc tout à l'heure
je j'inviterai à me rejoindre Bernard
Baudin Daniel ouper et Éric
tirouin
alors vous le savez cette thématique de
l'environnement elle me tient à cœur
depuis longtemps ça fait près de de 15
ans que je m'y consacre mes aventures
maritimes ont permis à la fois d'être
vraiment sur le terrain et et de voir à
la fois la beauté de notre environnement
quand on est à la rame sur un tout petit
bateau et qu'on est à 30 cm de la
surface de l'eau on voit l'environnement
tel qu'il est donc à la fois sa
magie que ça soit la biodiversité les
couleurs les baleines les dauphins et
puis la force de l'humain qui est
capable de s'emmener là où il a arrivêvé
d'être et cette petite étincelle de vie
qui nous fait résister pendant des mois
et des mois seul au milieu de cet espace
incroyable de mystère et à la fois ces
aventures là m'ont montré
malheureusement de près que ça soit les
pollutions marines que ça soit parfois
l'urbanisation excessive des côtes en
tous les cas l'impact de l'humain sur
nos toutes petites planètes et le fait
d'en faire le tour même si cette fois-ci
j'étais sur un bateau à voile m'a permis
de me rendre compte que cette planète
elle était finalement pas si grande et
que nous avons des ressources qui sont
limitées et ces ressources limitées
c'est de notre
responsabilité et nous dirigeants
politiques d'en assurer la continuité
pour les générations
futures
pourquoi aujourd'hui on est tous
d'accord tout le monde veut un nin à
respirer tout le monde veut léguer une
planète en bonne santé à ses enfants là
où nous différons chez les républicains
c'est sur la vision de cette politique
environnementale aujourd'hui moi je
crois dans un raisonnement posé réaliste
basé sur leseffet scientifique de
redonner de la place à la recherche à
l'innovation aux technologique et c'est
pour ça que vous avez accepté de me
rejoindre on veut un discours qui soit
basé sur les faits et pas seulement sur
les incantations aujourd'hui il faut
être dans le réel et proposer des choses
concrètes et aller jusqu'au bout et
arrêter d'opposer les uns aux autres il
y a pas d'un côté les les Gentils qui
parleraient aux arbres et de l'autre
côté tous les autres qui seraient des
méchant qui habiterai dans les villes
aujourd'hui on est tous d'accord sur ce
message là et je crois justement que
c'est la science le progrès qui va nous
permettre de basculer dans C
consommation dans ce développement plus
durable et c'est pour ça que l'économie
circulaire dont vous entendrez parler
tout au long de cette journée et des
années futures cette économie circulaire
c'est-à-dire de penser ce que l'on va
prélever dans la nature de savoir ce que
l'on va en faire et ensuite de
réutiliser et utiliser le déchet comme
une ressource vous savez les poubelles
n'existent pas dans la nature le déchet
peut être une ressource et et par
exemple en Corée du Sud aujourd'hui on
se bat pour récolter partout dans le
monde les még de cigarettes les mé de
cigarettes dont on sait que faire eux
ils se battent pour les racheter parce
qu'ils l'utilisent pour la fabrication
de batteries il y a un potentiel
incroyable c'est ça serait vraiment
sous-estimer l'homme et sa capacité
d'imagination que d'avoir la position
qui est parfois entretenue par les
écolos radicaux qui s'imagine qu'il
faudrait revenir à avant personne ne
veut revenir à avant qui veut revenir en
1750 quand l'espérance de vie était de
27 ans en
moyenne aujourd'hui on a grâce à la
science et aux évolutions une croissance
qui s'améliore une qualité de vie qui
s'améliore une qualité de l'air qui
s'améliore mais ce qu'il va falloir
c'est répondre à l'augmentation de la
population et à comment gérer malgré le
fait qu'on est de plus en plus nombreux
ces ressources qui sont limitées ce
besoin en énergie accrue qui va falloir
transformer en énergie renouvelable et
c'est toutes ces questions qui faut se
poser mais d'une façon pragmatique alors
pour commencer sur la partie vraiment en
lien avec le le domaine de
l'environnement j'ai j'ai voulu qu'on
qu'on fasse d'abord un point avec toi
Bernard de Flessel qui est avec moi au
Conseil Régional PACA qui est député des
bouchees du rô un point sur la COP 21
parce que cette COP 21 vous en avez
entendu réentendu réentendu on nous a
dit partout que ça avait été le le le
succès incroyable est-ce que ça a été
vraiment un succès qu'en est-il pour la
planète la France at-elle un rôle
exemplaire bon merci MAE euh oui tous
les titres extraordinaires qu'on a vu
fleurir à la fin de l'année sur le
succès de la COP 21 accord historique
trois points de suspension moi je dis un
accord et c'est tout en en quelques mots
quel était le sujet et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pendant la COP 21 bon faut
rappeler simplement que c'est sous
lesgit des Nations Unies depuis
pratiquement 25 ans que l'intégralité
des 194 pays se sont mis en quête de
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et c'est les scientifiques
d'abord qui ont été les premiers
finalement à alerté la puissance
publique et les et les pays en général à
travers le gèc le fameux groupement des
scientifiques au niveau mondial ils ont
commis plusieurs rapports le dernier un
peu plus d'un an et qu'est-ce qu'ils
ditent ce dernier rapport il dit un que
le réchauffement à 95 % est lié à
l'activité humaine donc pour les
climatosceptiques c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle deuxièmement que si nous ne
faisons rien à l'augmentation de la
température à la fin du siècle serait
aux alentours de 4 de5 voire 4 de 8
monter des EAU d'un m enfin enfin vous
connaissez tout ça par cœur donc là le
sujet est un sujet évidemment
d'importance et traditionnellement les
Nations Unies tous les ans fin novembre
début décembre organise une COP c'est
une conférence des partis on réunit tous
les partis les les les et donc tous les
pays euh euh sous l'égide des Nations
Unies
euh on a voulu en en en en 2015 à
travers la Cope de Paris essayer de
faire un coup médiatique et quand je dis
on c'est évidemment le gouvernement et
le président de la République car
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire il fallait
se substituer à l'accord de Kyoto le
dernier protocole important sur le
réchauffement climatique c'est le Kyoto
il avait été arrêté en 97 mis en œuvre
en 2005 et il se terminit en 2015 donc
il fallait prendre un successeur à Kyoto
et donc le président de la République a
sauté sur l'occasion en disant et si
nous faisions la COP 21 à Paris parce
que à ce moment-là nous pourrions avoir
l'espoir de faire un accord
juridiquement contraignant un accord
important au niveau international et
évidemment ça serait pas trop mauvais
pour mon image alors l'objectif de la
COP 21 c'était quoi à Paris c'était un
d'essayer de faire donc un successeur au
Kyoto donc un traité juridiquement
contraignant de d'essayer de limiter
l'augmentation du réchauffement à 2
degrés à la fin du siècle pourquoi 2
degrés parce qu'on sa qu'au-dessus je
dirais les les conséquences sont
dévastatrices à tout point de vue et et
et trit de le mettre en œuvre à partir
de 2020 puisque c'était un accord sur 5
ans alors il y a eu des points posi dans
cette affaire al les points positifs ils
sont surtout apportter finalement au
travail des Nations Unies car depuis 25
ans à travers les COP alors il y a eu
des échecs on se rappelle de Copenhague
en 2009 mais il y a eu des avancées
progressives le point positif de la COP
21 parce qu'il y en a un c'est que
environ 175 180 pays ont voulu faire un
effort et faire une feuille de route ce
qu'on appelle en jargon unien l'indc
c'està-dire une feuille de route c'estàd
voilà ce que je peux faire moi contre le
réchauffement climatique et voilà quel
est mon plan à 5 ans à 10 ans à 15 ans à
20 ans donc c'est en fait une une
changement de stratégie une changement
de logique on est parti au lieu de faire
du du du Top Down c'est-à-dire de
descendre du du sommet en disant voilà
ce qu'il faut faire et si vous ne faites
pas ça ça va pas marcher on a fait du
bottom up c'est-à-dire qu'on a pris le
le le le schéma à l'envers en disant au
pays faites-nous vos proposition
regardez un petit peu comment vous allez
faire les choses et comment ça va se
raduire donc c'est plutôt une démarche
intéressante et c'est c'est une démarche
qui est plutôt positive le seul petit
problème c'est que le résultat de tout
ça ben ne fait pas comme on dit chez
nous la maille c'est-à-dire que quand on
collationne les 180 fiches les 180
déclarations d'intention parce que ce
sont des déclarations d'intention de
tous les pays on n'est pas à 2 degrés on
est plutôt à 3° 5 ce qui veut donc dire
que le déclaratif ne suffit pas donc il
y a une bonne idée il y a un courant
plutôt de sympathie qui est passé il y a
une prise de conscience quand vous
déplacez dans tous les pays du monde
vous allez en Chine vous allez au Japon
vous allez un peu partout tous disent i
réchauffement climatique c'est important
nous on a un plan on vous présente notre
plan voilà notre plan donc chacun l'a
transmis dans dans sa feuille de route
et et ces feuilles de route sont remonté
aux Nations Unies mais quand on fait la
somme de ces feuilles de route si on les
additionne on n'est pas à de on est à 3
et demi donc ça pose un véritable
problème ça c'est c'est si en plus les
feuilles de route sont respecté deuxième
chose pourquoi serait-elle respecté
prendre un exemple très simple c'est
Kyoto Kyoto c'est c'est le dernier grand
accord sur le contre le réchauffement
climatique c'est plus de 55 pays qui
l'avaient signé et donc c'était un
traité ce traité il a été appliqué et il
a été appliqué à partir de 2005 jusque
donc fin 2015 et quand on regarde les
engagements qui avaient été pris dans le
Kyoto qui étaiit déjà des engagements
entre guillemets juridiquement
contraignants euh on avait pris un
engagement honeste faire baisser le CO2
de 5 % c'était quand même pas
extraordinaire résultat des courses
quand on a fait le le le le le schéma et
la somme des les résultats c'est plus 34
donc voyez que même avec un engagement
de ce de cet acabi là on y est pas
arrivé donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
évidemment pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique 1 évidemment
faut la faut la présence de tous les
pays c'est l'avantage de la COP 21 on a
réussi passz-moi cette expression à
embarquer quand même à peu près 180 pays
dans cette feuille de route et dans dans
leur feuille de route mais de il y a
deux choses qui nous manque c'est à la
fois l'argent les moyens financiers et
transfert technologique les moyens
financiers c'est catastrop
vous savez que l'épure financière qui
était prévu c'est de faire 100 milliards
de dollars par an à partir de 2020 pour
essayer de contraindre et et de changer
les choses aujourd'hui on est on a
engrangé c'est le fond vert qui s'en
occupe qui est basé en Corée 10
milliards donc 100 milliards d'objectifs
on est à du milliards fermes et sur les
10 milliards fermes quand on regarde les
projets qui sont lancés depuis la fin de
l'année 2015 il y en a
et ils sont auj alentour de 160 millions
de dollars donc vous partez de 100
milliards de dollars qu'il faut on sait
qu'on en a à peu près engrangé 10
milliards et qu'aujourd'hui on est en
train d'en mettre en œuvre environ 160
millions et que sur les h projets qui
sont lancés au Malaoui un peu partout en
Afrique il y en a un qui émerge c'est au
Sénégal pour refaire des terres
salinisées donc vous voyez que on est
très très loin de l'objectif ça c'est le
problème financier donc 1 les feuilles
de route c'est bien mais ça fait pas la
maille c'est-à-dire qu'on arrive pas à
notre objectif 2 degrés donc c'est un
problème de d'un point de vue financier
on y est pas non plus et tro sur le
transfert des technologies ça n'avance
pas les Nations Unies ont fait un je
dirais une commission de haut niveau
pour essayer de traiter le problème du
transfert de technologie parce qu'il
faut du transfert de technologie pour
aider les pays qui sont en voie de
développement et de ce point de vue-là
ça fonctionne pas les grandes firmes ne
veulent évidemment pas se départir de
leur brevet et cetera donc on donc on
un peu je dirais à côté à côté du
vélo de ce point de vue-là donc la
situation est à la fois c'est un verre à
demi plein quoi je veux dire donc
positivement il y a une prise de
conscience moi je fais les rapports
l'assemblée depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années à travers toutes les copes il y
a une vraie prise de conscience quand
vous allez un peu partout dans le monde
vous sentez que les gens disent oui il
faut lutter contre l'échauffement
climatique on va faire des efforts voilà
notre plan et cetera et quand on fait la
somme de ces efforts on y'y arrive pas
et puis d'un point de vue financier
c'est très complexe et d'un point de vue
technologique également donc la route
est longue merci merci Bernard alors
j'espère que ça vous
aura un petit peu éclairé c'est c'est
des grands sujets je pense que le fait
que on arrive à se réunir et le fait
qu'on arrive à parler de de ces
questions là est déjà une excellente
chose de penser bien à parler changement
climatique et pas forcément toujours de
rééchauffement mais de changement et on
est tous d'accord là-dessus après vous
avez vu dans les propositions on ouvre
le fond vert au financement privé parce
que la difficulté comme nous l'a
expliqué Bernard c'est quelles sont les
solutions au pays en développement que
va-t-on faire nous en Afrique parce que
ces pays africains qui n'ont pas accès à
l'énergie c'est plus tenable donc il va
bien falloir là-bas apporter des
technologies celles que l'on connaît et
que tout ça il va falloir de l'argent et
que si on nouvre pas le fond vert aux
donateurs privés on va en manquer je je
crois qu'on a euh un exemple à montrer
et c'est pour ça queon en viendra on y
reviendra dans la dans la table ronde
sur la partie énergie la France est
plutôt exemplaire du fait qu'elle n'a
met que trèss très très très peu elle
est un des des pays au monde qui éimet
le moins de de CO2 en vérité avec la
Suisse et grâce à son nucléaire donc on
peut pas à la fois prenez la COP 21
allit dire au monde entier qu'il faut
arrêter de polluer et puis nous-même
décider d'arrêter nos centrales
nucléaires comme le fait l'Allemagne en
rouvrant des mines à ciel ouvert de de
charbon donc ça c'est des choses qui
sont importantes à dire aujourd'hui il y
a une impulsion internationale il faut
pas oublier que si la France éimet aussi
peu de CO2 c'est parce queelle fait tout
produire en Chine et que c'est la Chine
qui parce qu'elle produit a besoin de
beaucoup d'énergie et donc va polluer
l'environnement maintenant les chinois
sont très nombreux que à à l'échelle
d'un chinois un chinois polluit pollue
largement moins qu'un Français et
considérablement moins qu'un Américain
donc il faut rappel aussi ces chiffres
là les vrais chiffres par exemple on
peut les donner la France c'est grosso
modo ce qui est intéressant c'est
l'émission de CO2 par capita par tête en
France c'est 5 5 et demi 5 tonnes et
demi les États-Unis c'est 17 multiplié
par 30 millions d'Américains la Chine
ils sont déjà à 8 8 tonnes par habitant
multiplié par 1ard250 millions voyez un
petit peu ce qui fait qu'en fait les les
grands polueurs c'est la Chine et les
États-Unis à eu deux ils font 40 % des
émissions mondiales pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée l'Europe c'est entre 11 et
12 % hein l'Europe qui est leader en la
matière qui a fait son plan règ des 3 x
20 les - 40 % et cetera qui a toujours
été à la pointe du combat en particulier
aussi la France euh c'est 11 à 12 % des
émissions mondiales donc si rien ne se
passe ailleurs à ce moment-là nous
sommes nous sommes en échec et le fameux
accord encore historique j'en ai marre
d'entendre ces histoires d'accord
historique je me rappelle qu'un grand
quotidien du soir l'année dernière avait
titré en première page accord
hisytérique entre les États-Unis et la
Chine par que on nous a rebattu les
oreilles avec cet accord moi j'ai bien
regardé les choses les États-Unis se
sont engagés à réduire leur CO2 de 25 à
28 % en 2025 mais ils partent d'un
chiffre qui est le chiffre de 2005
l'Europe elle quand elle fait son plan
de - 40 % elle part de
90 ce qui veut dire que l'effort des
États-Unis est rapporté à celui de
l'Europe c'est 10 %. et la Chine n'en
parlons pas la Chine a pris un accord
c'est vrai avec les États-Unis elle a
dit voilà moi je vais stabiliser mes
émissions de CO2 en 2030 je sais pas si
vous imaginez ça veut dire que de 2015 à
2030 elle s'autoris à continuer à
augmenter ses émissions de CO2 et qu'en
2030 peut-être elle les stabilisera vous
savez combien se vend de voiturees en
Chine aujourd'hui 21
millions 14 15 aux États-Unis et
beaucoup moins en Europe donc voilà
voilà les l'équation hein donc on est
encore une fois un peu loin du compte
mais il faut positiver comme je le dit
tout à l'heure je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure et bon il faut équilibrer les
choses et et foncer donc c'est
exactement ça on a vu le bilan on a eu
le constat bon maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et surtout comment est-ce
qu'on va investir dans la recherche dans
l'innovation pour trouver les techniques
à la fois de cestration du carbone si on
a du mal à les réduire parce que tout un
chacun a envie de la croissance parce
que la croissance naturellement dans les
bidenville et dans les favelas ça n'a
pas beaucoup de sens la décroissance la
croissance c'est l'accès à l'énergie
mais c'est aussi l'accès à la santé
l'accès à l'éducation et que tout ça
naturellement chacun en a on a envie et
besoin donc il va falloir qu'on qu'on
fasse fonctionner nos ménag et c'est ce
que l'on fait à travers le monde et les
solutions sont en sont en cours
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que on
avait besoin ici d'avoir des
spécialistes pour vous parler de ce
principe de précaution qu'on vous
voudrait remplacer par un principe de
responsabilité pourquoi parce que le le
principe de précaution qui a sûrement
été mis dans la Constitution avec plein
de bonnes intentions parce que tout un
chacun a envie d'être protégé
naturellement aujourd'hui s'est
transformé en un parapluie gigantesque
qui nous empêche d'agir et qui est un
finalement principe d'inaction et qui a
paralysé l'effort de recherche et qui a
fait beaucoup de mal et Marcel kout nous
en parlera notamment pour l'aspect
vraiment scientifique CNRS qui a fait
beaucoup de mal à à l'esprit pris
d'avant-garde scientifique français qui
a fait qu'il y a près de 22000
chercheurs qui sont partis aux
États-Unis pour exercer la profession
parce qu'ils sentent ici une une chape
sur leurs épaules une incompréhension et
que au final ça ne sert pas les intérêts
français donc aujourd'hui il ne faut il
faut préserver notre population prendre
les bonnes décisions mais en se basant
sur les faits et sur les rapports
scientifiques et non pas seulement sur
de l'émotionnel et c'est pour ça que
Monsieur raout vous avez accepté de de
de venir pour pour nous parlez vous en
tant que que médecin responsable chef de
service à la timon de de cette vision en
lien avec le principe de précaution et
ce qui nous intéresse souvent à premier
titre c'est-à-dire notre notre santé
notre qualité de vie euh peut-être
voilà très bien d'abord je je suis pas
un homme politique je suis un
scientifique et donc je peux pas vous
délivrer de messages simples et précuit
donc c'est pas ma
nature je sais pas euh donc on on vit
dans un monde qui n'a pas cessé qui ne
cesse pas de changer c'est ça change
tout le temps et ça va s'accélérer parce
que les moyens techniques que là et la
population humaine change tout le temps
et face à cette ces changements bien sûr
il y a des inquiétudes et qui sont plus
fortes dans ce pays que dans n'importe
quel autre pays au monde c'est dans ce
pays qu'on bouffe le plus
d'antidépresseurs c'est un des pays dans
lequel il y a le plus de suicide et si
vous voulez l'appel à la dramatisation
permanente est une des maladies de ce
pays est une maladie qui est politique
et journal tique et donc il faut au bout
d'un moment un peu se calmer regarder
les choses avec un peu de distance ce
qui s'est passé depuis 30 ans c'est que
nous avons gagné 10 ans d'espérance de
vie les gens qui voudraient et et cette
cette cette réaction se fait à droite
comme à gauche à droite on voit des des
chroniqueurs qui sont qui basculent dans
la nostalgie de monde qui n'ont jamais
existé qui n'ont pas connu d'ailleurs
mais enfin avant 68 on vivait 15 ans de
moins on vivait en 68 comme les
Sénégalais vivent maintenant d'accord
donc il faut un peu revenir sur terre le
monde actuellement on n pas du tout
d'évidence que le monde est en train
d'aller plus mal que ce qu'il allait
avant et donc la gauche en revanche elle
a basculé dans le principe de précaution
c'est-à-dire on arrête de changer le
monde ne doit plus changer doit plus
évoluer on voit bien d'ailleurs entre la
gauche et la droite que les que les
peurs du changement ne sont pas de même
nature il y en a qui ont peur des
mouvements de population il y en a
d'autres qui ont peur de la technologie
d'autres qui ont peur de la chimie je
vais vous donner quelques exemples y
compris sur le climat parce que pour moi
sceptique qui suis scientifique c'est un
compliment d'accord les gens qui ne sont
pas sceptiques sont des gens qui sont
des croyants moi je ne suis pas croyant
je suis sceptique je change d'avis tout
le temps au fur à mesure que les données
changent et par exemple sur le climat je
suis ravi que on fasse la COP 21 mais
comme j'ai de la mémoire je vous suggère
d'aller regarder ce que c'était que le
protocole de Montréal qui est un
protocole qui a été signé en 87 pour
empêcher le refroidissement de la
planète à l'époque où la planète avit
commencé à chauffer depuis 1983 et
c'était le premier protocole mondial où
tout le monde était enfin d'accord on
allait empêcher le refroidissement de la
planète et d'ailleurs moyen en quoi on a
remplacé les gaz réfrigérants par des
gaz réfrigérants encore plus émetteur de
de de de CO2 qui participe probablement
à l'émission massive de CO2 en
particulier d'Inde donc il faut être
prudent de la même manière que dans ma
génération le nucléar kine des Allemands
c'estàdire pas de nucléaire les a amené
alors qu'ils étaient en pointe sur le
plan écologique à devenir le pays le
plus pollueur d'Europe donc il il faut
faire attention au message simple parce
que l'enfer est pas fait bonnes
intentions contenu qu'est-ce que c'est
que le principe de précaution le
principe de précaution il est basé sur
le fait que pour répondre à cette espèce
d'angoiss générale il faut essayer de
prédire ce qui va se passer on ne prédit
pas malheureusement je crois pas plus
aux prophéties je crois aucune prophétie
dès que les choses sont complexes en
vité on peut pas les prédire et on
devrait au contraire les observer et
donc moi je je je je suis absolument
convaincu qu'il faut remplacer le
principe de précaution par un principe
de vigilance il faut regarder et nous
n'avons pas les outils de le faire et je
vais vous donner des des éléments qui
qui vous toucheront probablement nous
n'avons pas j'ai été conseiller deun
ministre de la santé il y a un certain
temps Jean-François mati où je lui
disais il va arriver un malheur parce
qu'on ne compte pas les morts dans ce
pays c'est-à-dire qu'on ne sait pas ce
qui se passe nous n'avons aucune
vigilance on avait peur de tout mais
finalement au milieu du mois d'août
après que je lui ai rendu avec les plus
grandes difficultés mon rapport parce
que son cabinet était contre j'avais mis
dans les propositions proposition 77 il
faut compter les morts toutes les
semaines pour savoir s'il se passe
quelque chose d'anormal et souvenez-vous
2003 c'est les croocs morts qui sont
arrivés pour dire écoutez on est en
rupture de stock de cercueil au milieu
du mois d'été ça n'est jamais arrivé
c'est comme ça qu'on a su qu'il y avait
la canicule c'est inoui on surveille
rien on a peur de tout on surveille rien
vous voulez que je donne un autre
exemple qui vous tiendra à cœur parce
que je crois que vous avez eu un enfant
à Tahiti j'ai un de mes élèves qui
direct qui dirige l'Institut Malardé qui
y a 2 ans et demi attiré l'attention sur
le fait qu'il y avait une épidémie
phénoménale avec Zika 80 % de la
population de Tahiti a eu une infection
à zica il y a eu plusieurs morts sur
place donc tout le monde s'est fichu
parce que c'était pas la métropole et
parce que la presse internationale ou
l'OMS n'en parlait pas et donc toute la
presse ne s'est préoccupé que d'une
chose c'est des bolas il y a eu zéro
français morts des bolas d'accord mais
personne ne s'est occupé de zik on s'en
est occupé simplement quand l'Amérique a
dit attendez il y a un problème au
Brésil alors que nous on avait eu 80 %
d'une population qui était infectée mais
il n'y a pas nous n'avons pas de règles
pour simplement être vigilant sur les
changements qui sont en train de se
passer donc tout va changer tout le
temps et si nous n'avons pas les outils
pour observer les changements et pour
réagir de manière précoce à ces
changements nous ne serons pas capable
d'y faire face et donc le principe du
précaution est une idée folle qui est
que nous pouvons prédire ce qui se passe
et ceci est c'est allié avec le fait moi
je vous suggère de regarder c'est un
exercice extraordinaire sur toutes les
grandes peurs soit le biphénol les
pesticid comparez simplement le
Wikipédia en français et le Wikipédia en
anglais vous verrez que c'est pas une
science juste Wikipédia en français
c'est univoque c'est c'est terrible tout
le monde est d'accord et vous regardez
en anglais c'est tout tout est beaucoup
plus balancé parce que la surface est
beaucoup plus grande et parce que nous
sommes les leaders de la peur mondiale
donc il y a vraie question à faire c'est
est-ce que pour en surrajouter à à
l'audience que nous sommes que nous
voulonser bien sûr faire peur aux gens
nécessite et donne beaucoup plus de
d'attractivité au discours que vous avez
c'est extrêmement facile de mobiliser la
peur parce que c'est un des fondements
de notre pensée mais au bout d'un moment
il faut s'arrêter ce peuple est au bord
de la crise de ner en permanence hein et
donc il faut s'arrêter voilà et donc il
faut revenir sur terre et dire bien
entendu il va garder risques tout
changement technologique tout changement
entraîne un changement d'écosystème tous
mais nous ne savons pas lequel à
l'avance je vais vous donner un exemple
qui est le cœur de ma spécialité le la
veille que qu' a installé les États-Unis
sur la mortalité c'est ce qui a permis
de découvrir la maladie légionnaire la
maladie légionnaire a été découverte en
1967 parce qu'il y avait une
surmortalité des hommes de plus de 50
ans dans une ville Philadelphie personne
ne l'a observé c'est les statistiques
qui l'ont observé 76 et vous voyez que
nous les milliers de morts de la de la
canicule personne ne les voyait à partir
de ça on a découvert que c'était en
partie lié à une nouvelle technologie
c'est-à-dire à la climatisation la
climatisation n'était pas entretenue
c'est des bactéries qui donnent ça qui
vivent dans à l'intérieur de l'eau et
donc la climatisation avait donné la
maladie légionnaire d'ailleurs l'hôtel
dans lequel c'est passé a fini par être
détruit parce qu'il avait mauvaise
réputation récemment a été découvert
d'une manière très inattendue en
Angleterre que la maladie des
légionnaires était plus fréquente chez
les chauffeurs de camion et bien entendu
on a tout de suite regardé est-ce que
c'est la climatisation des camions et on
s'est rendu compte que les chauffeurs
qui avaient une climatisation avait
moins de maladies de légionnaire que
ceux qui n'en avaient pas et la raison
je dire que qui a mis 2 ans
d'investigation c'est que les Ch les
chauffeurs qui n'avaient pas
climatisation roulit avec la fenêtre
ouverte et les bactéries de la maladie
légionnaire étent dans l'eau des
laves-glaces et que l'eau des lav-glaces
quand il balançaent leur leur le leurs
essuiesglace balancer de l'eau à
l'intérieur de la cabine parce qu'ils
avaient la fenêtre ouverte parce qu'il
av pas la climatisation et donc dans un
cas c'est la climatisation qui don la
maladie légionnaire dans l'autre cas
c'est l'absence de climatisation tout ça
c'est de l'observation vous pouvez pas
le prédire d'accord et donc tant qu'on
ne rentrera pas dans quelque chose qui
est peut-être contraire à notre culture
qui n'est pas très empirique qui n'est
pas très observatrice tant qu'on ne
rentrera pas dans un principe de
vigilance et qu'on mettra pas les outils
de surveillance etette vigilance et bien
nous ne serons pas capables de détecter
nous serons à la remorque des autres
pays qui auront découvert que quelque
chose d'anormal s'est passé parce que
nous ne sommes pas capables de le
découvrir avec les outils que nous avons
actuellement c'est
un merci beaucoup
ce que nous dit Didier raout est très
important pour moi c'est pour ça que je
suis très heureuse qu'il qu'il ait
accepté de de de nous parler parce que
c'est tout le projet des républicains
c'est-à-dire d'essayer de de d'arrêter
avec la diabolisation
l'instrumentalisation de la peur qui
fait beaucoup d'audimat qui fait
beaucoup de gros titres et qui
malheureusement n'est pas le reflet de
la réalité et que on veut être en
rupture justement avec cette vision là
avec une rupcture beaucoup plus avec une
vision beaucoup plus pragmatique
beaucoup plus réaliste beaucoup plus
encore encore une fois basé sur les
faits et sur l'analyse des faits donc en
prenant le temps d'analyser le risque
c'est pour ça que que Mar SK a accepté
d'être avec nous il est chercheurs au
CNRS travaille beaucoup sur les
biotechnologies et je voulais qu' qu'il
nous parle un peu de de cette peur que
l'on a sur la recherche sur le progrès
sur ces innovations
technologiques que que que qui c'est
vrai parfois est un petit peu monté en
épingle et et fait fuir nos chercheurs
et comment est-ce qu'on peut arriver à
transformer ça à croire de nouveau dans
ce succès en minimisant les risques et
en rassurant la population Marcel je
t'en prie bonjour à tous Merci de de
l'invitation euh je voulais ça m'
interpell que la la la la partie de
cette table ronde s'appelle réconcilier
l'environnement et et le progrès ça ça
devrait être évident quoi onut pas
concevoir l'environnement sans sans le
progrès et et pourtant on discute
aujourd'hui de de de cette questionl
et donc je pense qu'il faut faire moi je
suis biologiste mais j'aime beaucoup
l'histoire donc j'ai toujours tendance
quand je comprends pas un sujet d'aller
voir un peu historiquement comment ça
s'est passé donc la conscience
environnementale tout le monde le sait
elle a commencé dans les années 60 70 et
et et a des gens des personnes qui ont
porté cette cette conscience
environnementale des associations et il
faut les les féliciter pour pour pour
avoir su nous nous convaincre tous de
l'importance de de l'environnement ce
qui était pas évident à une autre époque
et pourtant ce ce mouvement là très
rapidement a a divergé dans certain
dogmatisme une idéologie où on a souvent
l'impression que le but c'est moins de
protéger l'environnement que de détruire
un pan de de de de l'industrie de de
l'activité économique qui est tombé dans
dans dans le radar et et donc souvent
sont mis en avant des des
thématiques qui ont un grand
retentissement médiatique par par
certaines associations et donc les
pouvoirs publics doivent doivent décider
souvent un peu dans dans une certaine
confusion et sollicite les les les
scientifiques pour pour avoir un avis et
voudrait souvent un avis simple clair et
et souvent c'est beaucoup plus plus plus
complexe que que ça et mais il faut faut
quand même souligner donc les
scientifiques la recherche elle cherche
la vérité elle détient pas la vérité
donc on aura forcément un certain nombre
d'incertitude et donc pour maîtriser les
les risques il faudra faire avec ces
incer titude je pense que did raout on a
bien parlé je vais pas y revenir et puis
il y a aussi des incertitudes qui sont
politiquement construites et c'est ça le
grand problème moi je dans dans mon
domaine mais dans d'autres domaines
aussi je connais beaucoup de collègues
ça'arrache les cheveux tous les jours ce
qui leur reste de de de voir ce qui ce
qui se dit dans les médias sur internet
des fois dans les médias de du 10
service
public on a des des choses
extrêmement bizarre pour le pour le
moins en tout cas déconnectter des
réalités scientifi pour rajouter un
point là-dessus il est certain que tout
un chacun vu les chiffres qu'on nous
donne je comprends que vous soyez que
vous soyez flippé on le serait à moins
tu es tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
ressort médiatiquement c'est assez
terrible c'est pour ça que moi je suis
allé voir l'Académie des Sciences je
vous demande de de monter un peu plus au
créneau mais vous tentez visiblement de
le faire mais c'est difficile de vous
faire entendre il y a des il y a des
médias quand on regarde la une on se
demande pourquoi on est encore en vie
quoi franchement c'est c'est comme ça et
et donc euh voilà il faut il faut je je
en tant que scientifique ce qui me
frappe c'est qu'on a on a l'impression
qu'on a perdu le sens de de de ce qui
est vrai de ce qui est faux et ça c'est
je pense que c'est extrêmement grave et
je pense qu'il va falloir travailler sur
sur ces points-là et alors pourquoi on
en est là je je pense qu'il y a eu une
une déconstruction de euh du progrès une
déconstruction de des valeurs des
Lumières une déconstruction aussi de
l'étanation enfin j'en va pas aborder ça
aujourd'hui mais mais c'est la même
idéologie et même une déconstruction de
la vérité donc souvent vous voyez des
gens qui viennent à la télé vous
expliquer ma vérité je suis désolé il y
a pas de ma vérité il y a peut-être ma
version mais il y a une une vérité mais
souvent parce que moi j'ai fait beaucoup
de de de de rencontre publiqu sur sur
les biotechnologies si vous dites voilà
la vérité en tant que scientifique là
vous allez vous faire euh insulter
carrément on n plus pas le droit de dire
ce qui est la vérité et donc on baigne
dans un espèce de de relativisme où tout
se vaut et vous avez des des des des
scientifiques qui vont être invités à
côté de un scientifique qui a peut-être
30 ans d'expérience dans un domaine à
côté de quelqu'un qui défend une opinion
bon respectable il a le droit on est en
démocratie il a le droit de défendre son
opinion mais on va le mettre strictement
sur le même point sur le même plan et
quand c'est sur le même plan encore en
tant que scientifique on est content
parce que des fois il y a même plus de
scientifique euh donc voilà c'est un un
un un point qui probablement cette
espèce de de de
confusion joue beaucoup sur la
perception des risques parce qu'on nous
on nous on nous assène constamment C ces
risques là lesffit scientifique qui
souvent sont sont sont relativement
rassurants parce qu'on vit quand même
mieux aujourd'hui ça a été dit aussi
qu'autrefois et et notamment en
agriculture l'agriculture aujourd'hui il
y a des gens qui ont une vision
fantasmée d'une agriculture qui n'
jamais existé c'était extrêmement dur de
d'être agriculteur quand on remonte ne
serait-ce que que 50 ans en arrière ne
pas parler de de de siècles en arrière
et donc il y a des progrès considérables
et on a on a oublié tout ça donc il faut
il faut aussi revenir un peu dans une
perspective historique de savoir d'où on
vient où on veut aller et puis de de
voilà de de voir ce que la science peut
apporter elle peut pas apporter tout
mais elle apporte quand même beaucoup on
sait pas tout mais on sait beaucoup et
et de de trouver les moyens
d'interaction class société mais pas sur
une j'insiste pas sur une base
relativiste pour pour pour gérer encore
une fois les scientifiques n'ont pas
décidé ils sont là pour pour donner des
avis et c'est aux élus au pouvoirs
publics de de décider alors Marcel
attentant donc on comprend bien que les
choses vont pas si mal on l'a vu dans la
table ronde avec toi pierregeorge sur
l'aspect de la pêche bon il y a du
poisson tout ne va pas si mal il y a
finalement il manque des bateaux c'est
plutôt l'inverse toi tu nous dis que
dans l'aspect notamment de l'agriculture
et on abordera tout à l'heure à table
ronde à agriculture et notamment
biodiversité c'est pareil tout ne va pas
si mal et on n' pas du poison dans nos
assiettes tous les jours comment faire
donc pour pour rassurer ceux qui sont
dans cette salle ceux qui nous
compteront j'espère plus loin dehors
comment faire pour pour changer la donne
aujourd'hui une autre écologie est-elle
possible celle que je tente de faire
porter depuis 15 ans et qui j'espère
prendra un autre relais en intégrant un
parti politique parce que c'est une
grande question comment faire pour faire
bouger les choses moi ça fait 15 ans que
je bosse dans le milieu associatif que
j'ai fait des programmes éducatifs dans
tout le milieu scolaire français que
j'ai travaillé au conservatoire duoral
et ailleurs on se dit là Nicolas Sarkozi
me me me propose de d'intégrer le parti
pour essayer de travailler sur un projet
j'ai accepté c'est à se demander est-ce
que c'est vraiment comme ça qu'on fera
bouger les choses je le pense parce que
je crois que c'est dans la politique que
l'on arrivera à insuffler une une autre
façon de faire est-ce que tu tu as des
clés pour pour pour changer
ça j'ai pas des clés je je suis pas non
même pas candidat au primairire voilà
ouf euh non mais je je en tant que
scientifique qu'est-ce qui vous pèse le
plus ici en France est-ce que cette
volonté qu'a le parti des républicains
de transformer le principe de précaution
par un principe de de responsabilité
d'innovation peut te paraître
essentiel à un moment donné je suis
toujours un peu un peu sceptique c'est
comme mon collègue c'est un peu notre
déformation mais il faut voir ce qui ce
qui va être mis derrière donc récemment
moi j'ai j'ai pu rencontrer des des
quelqu'un du des États-Unis qui
travaille pour le gouvernement des
États-Unis et qui ce qui est intéressant
un témoignage que je voudrais partager
ils sont en train de réfléchir à à la
modification de la réglementation sur
les biotechnologies donc il faut savoir
qu'il y a une une structure qui dépend
directement de la Maison Blanche qui
s'appelle l'Office of of science and
technology policy donc qui va faire des
propos qui a fait qui a déjà donné le
cadre de la réglementation sur les
biotechnologies et qui va proposer
maintenant une une modification et et
donc j'ai j'ai appris je je vous le
livre c'est traduit donc c'est les les
les objectifs de ce plan de
modernisation de cette réglementation
donc j'ai traduit en en français je vous
la livre je pense que c'est très
intéressant il s'agit donc évidemment de
de prendre en compte l'environnement
donc la phrase dit protéger la santé et
l'environnement tout en réduisant les
lourdeurs administratives et en évitant
de restreindre l'innovation de de de
façon injustifiée de stigmatiser les
nouvelles technologies ou de créer des
barrières au commerce voilà donc je
pense qu'il y a
une une une voix qui tout en
reconnaissant l'importance fondam ental
de la prise en compte de l'environnement
c'est c'est de pas de pas sacrifier et
souvent c'est pour certains c'est
délibérément que qu'on veut le sacrifier
de l'économie et je crois qu'on qu'il y
a des pistes pour pour avancer
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on on va
avoir une demande de mise sur le marché
d'un produit de biotechnologie ou ou
autre et puis on va on va
avoir face à cette innovation des
nouvelles réglementations des nouvelles
normes qui vont qui vont s'appliquer
souvent sans sans prendre en compte le
le l'impact par ailleurs que ça peut
avoir sur l'économie alors est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on veut vraiment protéger
l'environnement de manière un peu
dogmatique d'un côté ne pas prendre en
compte le l'impact sur l'environnement
je P qu'une piste de réflexion ça
pourrait d'avoir une réciprocité qui
d'ailleurs existe aux États-Unis
c'est-à-dire que chaque fois qu'on veut
cette fois-ci euh décréter qu'on aura
telle et telle réglementation telle et
telle norme de
s'instreindre aussi à voir quel peut
être l'impact sur sur l'environnement
donc une une certaine que ça soit pas
une course folle d'un côté vers vers
vers le le précautionnisme qui qui ne
s'arrête pas mais d'avoir l'obligation
légal de considérer aussi quel quel va
être l'impact et puis aussi de de de
réviser au bout de quelques années de
regarder on a pris telle et telle mesure
est-ce qu'elle était pertinente est-ce
qu'elle a été utile ou pas si si selle a
pas été utile ben onit des mécanismes
pour l'enlever et euh voilà je pense qu'
des pistes de de de réflexion et et
peut-être que ça rentre dans ce principe
de de responsabilité ou de principe
d'innovation je je je te remercie ça
tombe bien puisque la surtransposition
l'arrêt des surtransposition des des
règles ça fait partie du projet des
républicains cette volonté d'associer
écologie économie également et que le
travail que nous avons réalisé ensemble
dans notre groupe de travail à j'espère
te convient dans le document je voudrais
qu'on aborde la question transport avant
de passer à table ronde biodiversité
parce que le temps passe vite la
question transport elle est elle est
primordiale évidemment puisque parce que
c'est la principale dépllution c'est
quand même le transport dans nos villes
principalement dans le transport routier
et que là il va bien falloir qu'on pense
autrement et qu'on pense plus
intelligemment qu'on crée ces fameuses
villes vertes
aujourd'hui quelles sont les solutions
peut-être d'abord Daniel Mac qui
s'occupe des transports ici pour le
parti ton constat sur ce problématique
des transports et peut-être tes
solutions en tant que que comme
politique alors bon les solutions
d'abord il faud avoir la vérité la
vérité on vient de le dire il faut il
faut on l'a pas mais mais c'est des
messages espoir quand même bon on a BO
être virtueux en matière de de pollution
et et environnementale il en demeure pas
moins que nous avons d'énormes et que
nous pouvons faire d'énormes progrès en
matière de transport alors quelques
chiffres je vais pas trêre soporifique
mais mais pour bien mettre tout le monde
dans le film Le le les transports
connaissent depuis les années 80 une
croissance fulgurante en France en trme
de de transport de marchandise transport
routi représente 83 % c'est quand même
pas rien quand le transport ferroviaire
ne présente que 10 % et le fluvial 2 %
on voit déjà où on peut faire des
efforts en matière de en terme de
transport de voyageur le nombre de
voitures par Habitat a connu une une
forte croissance depuis 30 ans mais là
je n'invente rien et les transports
routiers sont les champions par contre
des dépenses énergie voilà alors il y a
des chiffres qui vont pas toujours
plaisir mais mais on est obligé de se
dire la vérité pour pouvoir évoluer et
après c'est pas pour autant qu'on
stigmatise mais les chiffres sont les
chiffres ils représentent les les les
transports routiers 32 % des dépenses
d'énergie globales et sont euh
responsables tout autant qu'on puisse
les les traiter de responsablees bien
sûr de d'un/4 des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en ce domaine en France
le transport routier est le plus
dépensier 80 % de l'énergie est consommé
par le secteur des transports avec en
tête de fil bien sûr la voiture plus de
50 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sont d aux voitures le reste est
imputable aux camions aux utilitaires et
aux transport aérien juste un exemple
qui est bien qui est bien frappant euh
pour le transport de voyageurs pour un
un un exemple que j'ai pris comme ça un
transport d'un trajet Paris-Marseille
ramené à une personne bien entendu hein
un avion provoque le rejet de 115 kg de
CO2 quand une personne en voiture en
aimit 136 kg et une personne voyageant
en TGV n'en aimit que 10 kg voilà c'est
des c'est des comment dire des chiffres
qui veulent rien dire et qui en même
temps sont parlants et qui voient de
quelle manière on peut faire évoluer le
le transport alors c'est pour ça qu'on a
été déçu dans notre famille politique de
voir que la loi sur la transition
énergétique n'aborde pas du tout la
question des transports et donc il faut
pourtant vraiment tu viens de l'évoquer
une politique forte dans cette dans sur
ce sujet bien sûr alors la la priorité
doit être donnée aux solutions
permettant d'apporter des économies
d'énergie pour réduire l'impact des
transports sur sur l'environnement deux
pistes quand même d'amélioration pe
peuvent être envisager le développement
de nouvelles technologie bien sûr on en
parle depuis le début il faut pas avoir
peur de nouvell technologie mais il faut
don les moyens de de les mettre en place
et et le changement d'habitude bien
entendu le temps me manquant donc je je
me concenterai que sur le transport de
voyageur je pense qu'il faut développer
le transport en commun des des des
transports en commun viable fiable et et
qui donne une qualité environnementale
beaucoup plus importante que que que
l'idée qu'on qu'on en a déjà parce que
c'est l'image qui est terrible
euh alors bien sûr le le le financement
il faut plus qu'il pèse sur monde
économique voilà un mot là-dessus sur le
financement il faut savoir qu'en France
le transport des voyageurs est financé
par l'entreprise ça s'appelle le VT le
versement transport le versement
transport le gouvernement aujourd'hui a
décidé de le passer aux entreprises qui
étaient de 9 à 11 salariés donc manque
de recette qui n'a pas été compensé et
les les collectivités aujourd'hui euh
financent le transport à hauteur par le
budget principal à hauteur de 30 % on a
un déficit ce que les conséquences de
tout ça c'est quoi c'est que nous nous
n'arrivons plus à nous mettre à niveau
nous n'arrivons plus à être être avoir
des niveaux performants de de de
rénovation un petit peu de nos parcs de
de nos parcs de de camions et de et de
bus et et forcément on court pas après
les nouvelles technologies et c'est
dommage et le deuxième effet c'est que
quelle quelle énergie devons-nous
choisir il n'y a pas de fil conducteur
il n'y a pas de de vision nationale à ce
niveau on laisse aujourd'hui les régions
les départements faire ce qu'ils veulent
c'està-dire tantôt nous allons aller
vers vers l'électrique tantôt vers le
vers le gaz tantôt vers l'hybride tantôt
il y a pas de fil conducteur alors que
aujourd'hui si vous achetez une voiture
électrique eu égard au fait que un les
batteries ne sont pas encore au point
pour avoir une capacité de développement
de on n pas de lieu de chargement donc
c'est tout ça qu'il faut évidment ch y a
il y a tout ça à changer mais il faut
des des des financements des des
financements totalement différents on ne
peut pas continuer à plomber les
entreprises qui plomb bien sûr l'emploi
qui plomb le développement des
entreprises et et et les rendre
uniquement responsable du financement
des collectivités et des transports
voilà voà je pense qu'on a besoin de
réfléchir là-dessus on parlait tout à
l'heure un peu un aparté de l'écotaxe
est-ce qu'il faut le remettre sur le sur
le dans le débat le point de TVA dont on
parle depuis très longtemps est-ce qu'il
peut pas compenser un petit peu en
baissant un peu le VT et et pour
soulager le le monde de l'entreprise de
nous aider à développer le transport et
bien sûr toutes les technologies qui
vont avec je crois qu'il y a une grosse
réflexion à voir dessus il y a des
solution mais il faut avoir le courage
de les aborder et puis non pas
stigmatiser les transports parce que les
transports on en a besoin mais
simplement dire voilà il faut maintenant
essayer d'être un petit peu plus
performant un petit peu plus visionnaire
avoir un fil conducteur une colonne
vertébrale et qu'on a tout un peu dans
la même direction alors merci Daniel
justement quand tu dis il faut avoir
cette vision il faut faut assurer ce
progrès ces évolutions alors Louis toi
sur cette évolution sur le numérique sur
ces Smart City sur comment évaluer en
temps réel les embouteillage minimiser
le transport c'est quoi ton point de vue
là-dessus alors peut-être auparavant si
tu me le permet de remarques j'avais un
grand oncle qui était un immigré italien
qui est venu travailler en France il y a
quelques années de ça au niveau de la
deuxème Guerre mondiale il me disait on
travaillait 60 Hees par semaine on avait
pas de sécurité sociale on avait rien un
costume dans l'année c'était un grand
maximum et on chantait alors c'est vrai
qu'on baigne dans un pays aujourd'hui
qui est plus inquiet que l'Irak ou où il
y a des explosions tous les jours qui
est plus inquiet que la Syrie et c'est
un phénomène étrange alors j'entends les
scientifique et moi je suis maire de
commune de C surmer donc ce que je
souhaite c'est et c'est ce que souhait
d'ailleurs les concitoyen ce sont des
résultats regardeer dans le rétroviseur
ne sert pas à grand-chose casser le
thermomètre non plus donc qu'est-ce
qu'on a dans les transports on a tu l'as
très bien dit Daniel on a aujourd'hui
plus de 30 % dans les milieux urbains dû
à la pollution du au transport alors on
a plusieurs pistes on a la piste bien
sûr de travailler sur le véhicule
particulier l'automobile on peut viser
les 2 km au 100 et donc effectivement il
y aura beaucoup moins de pollution mais
on a une double
pollution sur lequel on insiste
peut-être pas assez la première
pollution c'est une pollution à gaz à
effet de serre parce que la planète est
malade tout à l'heure tu l' très bien
dit effectivement il faut lutter contre
ces gaz à effet de serre qui touch la
planète mais qui nous touche assez peu
parce que on peut encore respirer du CO2
je le dis s contrôle des scientifiques
on n tombera pas trop malade par contre
la pollution du au transport au
développement justement des déplacements
c'est une pollution locale avec des NOx
avec des hydrocarburesulés avec des
particules ça c'est votre santé la votre
et donc il faut travailler sur les deux
donc on travaille on doit travailler sur
les véhicules particuliers sur les
automobiles tout le monde en a bon qui
permet de se déplacer mais deuxème sujet
et on y arrive sur les transports en
commun transport en commun doit être un
transport ici à Paris la une des villes
les plus riches de France le taux de
motorisation ce que l'appelle le taux de
motorisation est un des plus faibles
sinon le plus faible de France dans les
milieux urbains pourquoi ben parce que
vous avez des transports en commun ici à
Paris digne de ce nom avec des bus des
métros et en plus globalement ça
fonctionne pas trop mal mais nous comme
mode qui venant de la région PACA où on
a le taux hein d'arrêt de travail le
taux d'indisponibilité
matériel au-dessus de la moyenne nous
avons des transports en commun qui ont
généré les naufragés du TER voilà où on
anné donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
pour avancer sur les transports dans les
transports en commun commun je rappelle
que un bus ça remplace 25 voitures que
un tram c'est 75 véhicules au niveau de
la pollution donc dans les milieux
urbains dans il est clair qu'il faut
favoriser les transports en commun et tu
l'as très bien dit Daniel des transports
en commun de
demain le parc des véhicules
particuliers se change en 15 ans c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup ça nous remonte
à Euro Z0 bon le parc des véhicles
des transports en commun se change un
peu plus rapidement mais aujourd'hui
nous devons aller vers des véhicules
hybrides véhiculle électrique pour avoir
le moins de pollution locale sur place
nous devons aussi travailler avec la
ville intelligente pourquoi B parce que
vous vous êtes tous rendus compte que
depuis quelques années mais c'est très
court on a ça on a un ordinateur qui se
balade avec nous d'ailleurs on a une
puce en fait comme les chiens on sait où
on est à tout moment
ou vous allez pas rendu compte vous
battez contre les libertés pour le truc
le machin et on est tous pués avec ça
hein on sait où on est exactement et à
quelle heure en plus donc et là personne
proteste c'est étrange donc nous avons
tous ça et ça ça nous permet de savoir
déjà d'ors et déjà que le bus va arriver
à tel arrêt à telle heure ça pourrait
nous dire demain que nous devrions
prendre tel ou tel moyen de transport
c'est-à-dire éventuellement une voiture
en covoiturage on a des en France on
n'est pas mauvais surt hein on a des
start-ups qui sont particulièrement
bonnes d'ailleurs elles partent aux
États-Unis la plupart du temps après bon
parce qu'on sait pas les conserver mais
aujourd'hui je suis tombé par hasard sur
le développement des transports avec
aujourd'hui une start-up qui propose
l'autoopper sur euh le smartphone voilà
donc donc voilà tout ce que nous pouvons
faire il y a tout est ouvert nous
partons d'une réalité qui n'est pas
extraordinaire he la pollution dans les
villes existent mais on peut faire
beaucoup mieux si on le veut j'aime
entendre Louis negre et son enthousiasme
je suis désolée on a un sujet qui est
tellement vaste je voudrais peut-être il
va falloir que vous laissiez quelques
places pour faire monter la table ronde
biodiversité forêt et eut je appelle mes
côté Bernard Baudin Alain Perre sénateur
ERC tiroouin pour la FNSEA le le sujet
de l'environnement le temps qui monte
sur SC est un sujet tellement vaste ça
m'a pris près des 11 derniers mois de
travail avec une soixantaine d'experts
parce que ça aborde tous les sujet merci
encore à tous ceux qui ont été là merci
Monsieur Raoul d'avoir été là merci
Marcel
euh on voudrait vous en parler pendant
pendant des heures tellement ce sujet
est large et touche tous les tous les
secteurs alors sur la biodiversité sur
la nature sur donc l'agriculture il y a
beaucoup de choses à dire on a très peu
de temps avant de passer à table rond
l'énergie qui est quand même un gros
morceau également moi je voulais
vraiment entendre bon Bernard Baudin
parce que je voulais qu'on essaie de
réconcilier les uns et les autres et
réconcilier euh les agriculteurs avec
l'environnement les chasseurs avec les
agriculteurs et l'environnement les
marins pêcheurs également et d'arriver à
chacun à se parler parce que personne a
intérêt à détruire son environnement et
non encore moins l'environnement dans
lequel il travaille donc peut-être un un
un mot Bernard je te laisse prendre le
le micro tu président de la Fédération
nationale des chasseurs et et je crois
que préserver l'environnement c'est
quelque chose qui te touche en fait bien
tout d'abord mode je te remercie d'avoir
pensé à faire intervenir le monde de la
chasse et son représentant dans un
discours sur la biodiversité j'y suis
extrêmement sensible c'est vrai et nous
devrions bien entendu nous sommes les
premiers intéressés par la biodiversité
par une grande richesse je voudrais
rappeler simplement quelques chiffres ce
ne sont pas les miens ce sont ceux de
l'étude anglaise bip la chasse en France
aujourd'hui c'est
1 pratiquants c'est 3 milliards 600
millions de chiffres d'affaires c'est
200li2 sur d'économie sur le
PIB c'est
28600 emplois pérennes c'est 70 millions
d'heures de bénévola donc ça
véritablement sa place sur le territoire
et sur le territoire national aussi bien
que sur le territoire d'autr m alors la
chasse a énormément été modifiée depuis
la seconde guerre au départ c'était une
chasse cuillette on prélevait c'est tout
ensuite il y a eu la chasse gestion dans
les années 70 où le chasseur a bien
compris que la ressource n'était pas in
puisable et qu'il fallait mettre en
place des ce qu'on appelle des plans de
chasse des côas en fonction des
effectifs en fonction des milieux et
donc ça a été pendant ces 30 dernières
années l'utilisation et aujourd'hui nous
sommes passés à une autre aire c'est la
chasse durable la chasse durable ça veut
dire quoi et bien c'est d'abord il faut
qu'il y ait des territoires qui soit
pérenne qui soit riche qui soit
entretenu ensuite il faut du gibier il
faut des chasseurs et il faut
aujourd'hui une reconnaissance sociétale
donc reconnaissance sociétale et là tu
as abordé nos relations puisque la
chasse est en relation étroite avec le
monde agricole monde agricole qui s'est
considérablement modifié au fil des ans
et les les forestiers aussi que
j'englobe puisque la forêt bien entendu
est très concerné par l'activité
syynégétique alors je dis tout
simplement si la chasse était interdite
et j'ai d'ailleurs fait un film
là-dessus en France ce qui a été le cas
dans le canton de Genève en Suisse où
sous la pression des ONG on a interdit
la chasse ça a été une catastrophe une
catastrophe écologique parce que il a eu
un développement considérable de
certaines espèces notamment le sanglier
les servidés qui ont un impact très fort
le sanglier sur le monde sur les terres
agricoles et les servidés sur les
forestiers et donc ça a duré 3 ans on a
mis l'armée pour essayer de réduire les
populations ça n'a pas marché c'est pas
leur cœur de métier et donc et bien on a
réouvert la chasse donc il faut voir
l'utilité je crois que ce serait une
véritable catastrophe alors cette chasse
c'est vrai qu'elle a été elle a évolué
elle a évolué et notamment notre image a
évolué il a fallu le faire tu es bien
placé pour le savoir je crois que
aujourd'hui le chasseur doit paraître
comme un gestionnaire s'il n'est pas
gestionnaire il ne pourra pas poursuivre
son activité vous savez en matière de
gestion il y a eu plusieurs formes aussi
il y a eu d'abord la non gestion
c'est-à-dire qu'on laisse faire ensuite
il y a eu la gestion étatique il y a une
gestion étatique et en France on est
dans cette situation je rappelle que le
code
d'environnement 240 pages concernne la
chasse ça veut dire qu'on a vraiment une
pratique réglementé et puis il y a une
nouvelle approche de la chasse qui
correspond un peu à ce que etonor Strom
prix Nobel de l'économie dans les années
2010 2009 avait dit la chasse la gestion
par les utilisateurs l'utilisateur a
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait une
biodiversité qui soit riche à ce qu'il
ait des territoires qui produisent et
cela c'est une nouvelle approche dans
laquelle nous nous lançons merci merci
beaucoup de nous apporter ce témoignage
là parce que c'est vrai que cette
gestion des écosystèmes ça fait partie
du discours de de l'écologie c'est pour
ça que je voulais entendre également
Alain houper qui est sénateur de la Côte
d'Or parce que il y a parfois une une
idéologie sur la gestion des écosystèmes
qui fait parfois plus de tort que de
bien et et donc sur cette gestion du
patrimoine naturel français quelle est
ta
position je suis je fais un peu de
politique puisque je suis sénateur de la
Côte d'Or sénateur du montraachel de la
roman Conti
mais avant tout je me sens venir de ma
profession je suis médecin radiologue et
comme les deux premiers intervenants de
tout à l'heure j'ai été élevé à l'école
du
doute et c'est important et je vais vous
exprimer mes doutes contre les
certitudes de l'administration et de
l'écologie à la française je suis passé
tout à l'heure pour venir devant le
boulevard Saint-Germain j'ai vu ce
superbe hôtel particulier où il y a le
ministère de l'Environnement qui est un
peu à l'image de ce ministère où
l'écologie actuellement elle est faite
par des gens en costume cravate je te
pris une mexcuser je ne veux pas opposer
non plus la ville à la campagne mais des
gens qui sont éloignés de la réalité du
terrain et qui surtout qui ont jamais
mis les pieds en tant que sénateur je
suis rapporteur à la commission des
finances de du budget de l'agriculture
de la forêt et de l'agroalimentaire et
j'ai fait un rapport que vous pouvez
consulter sur la forêt faire de la
filière forêt bois un atout pour la
France la France c'est le
4e paysage forestier européen un/3 de de
la France est peuplé de forêt pour la
chasse en particulier c'est important la
synergétique 60 milliards de de chiffres
d'affaires mais 6 milliards de déficit
dans la balance commerciale qui elle en
fait 60 milliards donc 10 % de la du
déficit de la balance commerciale c'est
la forêt qui est très mal exploitée 2
tiers de la forêt est privé on l'accuse
de tous les mots parce qu'elle
appartient à des propriétair privé elle
est morcelée mais souvent elle est
bénéficiaire et un/ers elle est gérée
par l' NF et là on assiste à des des
aporis qui sont complètement françaises
parce qu'en France on a complètement
désinstrualisé notre pays
on a de moins en moins de Syrie on coupe
nos grumes et nos grumes qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait monsieur le rapporteur des
transport on les met dans des bateaux
pour servir de l'Est pour aller en Chine
et ça revient chez nous chez le roi
Merlin plein de solvant et en parquet
parquet marqué pays du châtillonnet donc
de chez moi et on amène aussi de la
pierre pour servir de l'Est qui vient
aussi de chez moi du pays du
Châtillonnais où il y avait un un grand
etthnologue qui habitait à côté chez moi
qui s'appelait Claude levistros qui
parlait de manière intelligente de
l'écologie et la pierre elle revient
coupée mais souvent dans le mauvais sens
c'estàd qu'elle gèle
donc il faudrait revenir un peu comme
l'Allemagne comparaison n'est pas raison
mais les Allemands ils ont une plus
petite forêt mais ils ont vraiment une
confrontation entre les publics privés
et entre la Val et la monont comme tu
l'as dit tout à l'URE donc on a besoin
de de mieux gérer not notre forêt
peut-être de se faire aider par la
banque publique d'investiss de peut-être
de de baisser les charges pour pour tout
ce secteur d'activité c'est des
propositions que vous allez retrouver
dans dans le document on a beaucoup
investi dans le boisénergie avec des
aides publiques et il y a eu un effet
d'auben beaucoup de communes surtout des
villes on cré des chaudières à bois et
maintenant on voit des norias de camions
130 camions pour une chaudière à Dijon
qui vienent du Jura 150 km 130 camion
par jour ça fait un hectare par jour qui
est brûlé pour pour faire du CH publ et
qui qui tient qui est rentable parce que
il y a pas encore d'isolation dans ces
le jour où il y aura une isolation c'est
dans dans dans tous les bâtiments c'est
ces chères ne seront plus rentables donc
on est complètement dans dans une aporie
on voit une forêt
avec les gens je suis très respectuable
des eau et forêt des ingénieurs des eau
et forêts mais maintenant ce sont un peu
des bobo
68ard qui en tant que MRE vous disent on
coupe les brumes mais on laisse tout sur
place en andin la forêt est dévastée
vous ne pouvez pas marcher c'est même
dangereux hein de traverser un nin avec
un fusil moi qui suis chasseur la forêt
de Trona qui a été construit par Colbert
pour que faire les trois Mâ du 21e
siècle malheureusement on na pas fait 3
mois avec on a fait on fait des des
tonneaux le général de Gaulle qui
regardait à gurgil Château de son tyul
la forêt de Châtillon et qui a trouvé
merveilleuse
doit se retourner dans sa tombe nous
sommes devant une gestion de la forêt il
faut revoir vraiment les les
prérogatives de l'ONF qui est une
administration dans l'état
qui qui est hors hors sol qui est hors
sol et une forêt privée avec 150
hectares vous arrivez à faire un emploi
la forêt publique il faut 2000 hectares
pour faire un emploi donc il y a quand
même une grosse différence et là on a
des marches de progr fait et je voudrais
aussi parler de la loi sur l'eau eau et
forêt qui est une calamité française
souvenez-vous de Monsieur Pompidou il
disait arrêtez de faire des lois pour
emmerder les
Français la loi sur l'eau c'est une
calamité parce que elle a réussi à créer
34 régimes de police de l'eau qui se
superposent et qui sont là pour emmerder
les mè pour emmerder les particuliers
qui sont possesseurs d'un bout de
rivière c'està-dire que les
escrologistes du boulevard Saint-Germain
ont réussi à faire en
sorte je suis d'accord avec lauité
écologique mais actuellement à coup de
Carter Pilard et je viens du du toit du
monde occidental où il y avait Henry
vinsen celui qui avait la ver avec son
son velour côtelé to du monde occidental
c'est le monde son Bernon d'un côté il y
a la Loire de l'autre côté il y a la
Méditerranée de l'autre côté il y a la
mer du Nord
et l'eau l'eau c'est important et dans
mon département à coup de caterpilard on
est en train c'est là où est né l'épopée
cistercienne on est en train de
détruire tous les ouvrages d'art qui ont
été créés par les cistercien vous savez
les biafes qui retiennent l'eau les
vanages on les a pas entrenu pendant des
années çaassure ça fait une tte grise
d'entretien il faut revenir sur cet
entretien pour pour faire en sorte et
puis on eff face à des villes qui ont
été très
imperméabilisées et puis quand il pleut
tout va dans la rivière et c'est la
chasse d'eau à Vaison laomène donc il
faut revenir sur cette loi sur l'eau
parce que elle irrite tout le monde et
elle est contre-productive on fait ça
pour le poisson c'est sûr que le poisson
aura un bel horizon qu'est-ce qu'il va
avoir comme horizon des
des paysages hérissés
d'éolienes et quand on sait que les
éoliennes ça tourne quand il y a du vent
et on a besoin d'électricité quand il
fait chaud quand il fait froid et ça
s'appelle des anticyclones l'éolienne ça
marchera quand on pourra stocker
l'électricité c'estàdire qu'on pourra
avoir des piles électriques et quand on
pourra modifier la Loi sur l'Eau faire
des retenus cinaires comme ils ont fait
au canari c'estàdire faire remonter
l'eau en altitude et la faire
redescendre avec les turbines et je
pense que tous nos réseaux d'eau la
France elle est magnifique parce qu'on a
des réseaux on a des bassins verersants
magnifiques on pourrait les équiper de
petites turbines qui créent des emplois
qui créent l'aménagement de la rivière
actuellement vous n'avez même plus le
droit de curer un fossé on merci merci
beaucoup on va on va parler de cette
politique énergétique de l'eau dans la
table ronde qui va commencer dans dans
dans 5 minutes mais c'est vrai que quand
on parle de l'eau on parle forcément
aussi de l'agriculture la qualité de nos
eau sont est entretenue par et la
qualité des sols par nos agriculteurs
moi j'ai pris position il y a pas si
longtemps que ça lors de la convention
agriculture sur la thématique les
agriculteurs sont en réalité les
premiers écologistes ça m'avait valu les
foudres de nos amis écolos radicaux mais
la vérité elle est que c'est vous qui
dont dépend cette qualité des sols et
c'est vous qui êtes le constructeur de
la biodiversité alors est-ce que cette
surtransposition des lois cette
réglementation à outrance dont tu nous
parlais là est-ce que c'est quelque
chose dont réellement vous souffrez au
quotidien oui c'est clair que la
surtransposition on en crève tous les
jours dans notre secteur d'activité moi
c'est vrai que par rapport à ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure sur sur toutes
les peurs je vrais quand même rappeler
et on y tient c'est que en fait nous
agriculteurs en fait on vous nourrit
matin midi soir parfois à goûter aussi
et c'est vrai que on a une mission et un
rôle extrêmement important oui tout à
fait et
euh par rapport à ça on est aussi
producteur de biodiversité on est aussi
producteur d'eau potable on est aussi
protecteur du climat et on est
protecteur de de la société face aussi
aux inondations et un certain nombre de
choses alors je je vais détailler avec
un ou deux exemples chaque fois quand je
dis producteur de biodiversité je vais
vous parler de bouchon de champagne
alors vous allez vous demander quel est
le rapport alors je sais que mon voisin
de gauche le sa on travaille
effectivement avec avec les chasseurs
notamment en Champagne euh pour essayer
de développer la biodiversité et vous
savez qu'en Champagne un bosquet un
petit un petit un petit bosquet ça
s'appelle un bouchon voilà et donc
aujourd'hui en fait on a mis en place un
certain nombre de de de partenariats
tous ensemble pour essayer de placer un
certain nombre de bouchons à travers
toute la Marne et c'est vrai que c'est
une association qui s'appelle symbiose
qui est présidée par le président de la
FDSEA de la Marne euh qui marche
extrêmement bien et et tout cela en fait
c'est des initiatives qu'on est en train
de développer partout sur le territoire
et c'est vrai que c'est important de
pouvoir discuter d'être sur le lien sur
le terrain et donc sur nos champs sur
nos bordures de champ on peut
effectivement et et on implante un
certain nombre de d'outils de la
biodiversité mais la biodiversité c'est
aussi tout simplement par la diversité
des cultures et ça pour nous c'est
important de pouvoir diversifier
l'ensemble des cultures et et c'est par
ce biais-là qu'on arrive à avoir un
milieu ouvert puisque la biodiversité se
fait grâce à des milieux qui sont
ouverts et non pas faire fermé quand je
dis producteur protecteur du climat tout
à l'heure on parlait du climat et et je
pense notamment au gaz à effet de serre
alors c'est vrai que dans le régime de
la peur tout est bon voilà sauf que
l'essentiel c'est que par exemple en
céréal une céréales avec avec sa graine
ça capte SEP fois plus de gaz à effet de
serre que ça en en aimé y compris avec
les intranss avec le tracteur avec tout
ce qu'il y a dedans et effectivement la
plante entière c'est SEP fois plus de
gaz à effet serre qui est cap
et pourquoi bah parce que avec la forêt
on est les seuls on est les seules
activités qui s'appelle la photosynthèse
avec les plantes qui permet de capter
les gaz à effet de serre c'est le
principe de la photosynthèse et donc
plus il y a de la production de
photosynthèse plus de la la production
agricole plus effectivement on capte les
gaz à effet de serre donc on est bien
protecteur de climat on est producteur
d'eau potable pourquoi bah parce que
effectivement toutes les villes qui ont
des stations d'épuration aujourd'hui ben
tous les déchets qui sont à l'intérieur
des stations d'puration qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait et bien en fait on l'pend sur
les champs et grâce à notre nos cultures
grâce au sol en fait elle est à nouveau
filtré pour pouvoir retourner dans la
nature de façon propre donc on a aussi
un rôle extrêmement important dans le le
cycle hein tu parlais tout à l'heure
effectivement du du cycle un peu de de
tout ça et notamment des déchets il y a
pas de
déchets circulaire tout à fait et puis
on est aussi protecteur par rapport à
l'eau où je partage totalement ce qui
vient d'être dit bien évidemment donc je
veux pas le redire par rapport à l'eau
aussi il faut savoir que voilà par
exemple une ville comme Paris elle est
protégée aujourd'hui il y a tout un
système en cas d'inondation il y a
l'inondation d'abord des champs
agricoles et c'est des choses qui sont
prévues tout tout autour de la ville de
Paris un peu partout donc on a un rôle
essentiel dans toute cette protection de
la biodiversité de l'eau et et c'est
bien le thème de cette table ronde alors
maintenant pour y arriver on a un
certain nombre d'attentes un certain
nombre de besoin peut-être que tu peux
aussi préciser que l'agriculture d'il y
a 20 ans n'est plus d'actualité
aujourd'hui qu'aujourd'hui votre
profession l'a considérablement évolué
et ce qu'on entend parfois c'est des
choses qui existaient il y a peut-être
20 ans mais qui n'existent plus
actuellement oui tout à fait si je
prends juste un exemple par rapport à je
rebondirai sur ce qui a été sur la table
précédente on parle des herbicides des
phytosanitaires quelque chose comment
comment on peut faire bah l'agriculture
de demain c'est pas de revenir à hier
c'est au contraire d'aller plus loin
aujourd'hui on travaille sur des robots
qui vont avoir la capacité alors non pas
on va pas remettre des gens à biner les
champs mais en fait aujourd'hui il y a
des robots qui sont capables et c'est en
pleine voie de développement qui sont
capable d'aller désherber
mécaniquement effectivement les
mauvaises herbes et les reconnaître avec
des drones qui volent au-dessus des
champs et aujourd'hui on est en train de
finaliser la reconnaissance des
mauvaises herbes depuis depuis des
drones donc ça c'est l'agriculture de
demain et c'est une agriculture plus
propre plus respectueuse mais qui a
besoin d'innovation et de recherche et
c'est vrai que moi ce qui me tient à
cœur et je tiens à te féliciter et puis
reprendre les les propos d'Eric vers en
en introduction et effectivement le
principe de précaution il doit évoluer
vers un un principe de responsabilité et
un principe d'innovation je pense que la
France aujourd'hui a un besoin énorme
d'innovation et de recherche pour aller
de l'avant c'est de notre responsabilité
je pense que c'est quelque chose de
capital on le voit effectivement
sur les débats qu'on va avoir là au
Sénat par rapport à la loi biodive où
effectivement on voit qu'il y a
différents camps qui s'affrontent entre
celui de l'interd tion interdiction
totale ou celui de la responsabilité
celui de l'encadrement de mettre un
certain nombre de mesures pour avancer
et donc je pense qu'effectivement il est
capital d'aller dans ce sens merci merci
à tous hein je sais que le le temps est
est court on a j'espère grâce à ces
intervenant de qualité pu casser
quelques idées reçues de cette pensée
unique qui parfois déteint un peu trop
loin et ce que tu dis c'est vrai que
cette conclusion est est jolie c'est
finalement la religion écologiste qu'on
entend
à tort et à travers est bien différente
d'une science de l'environnement qui
prend à la fois en compte les besoins de
la société et la préservation de
l'environnement et c'est pour ça qu'on
va attaquer la table ronde énergie